I can play Queenie looks like it all
split queen c-5a click Queen d8 maybe
y'all split queen oh I give him Queen 83
whoops
lips maybe I have Queen b6 though maybe
it's still kind of okay it's not great
I'm down upon probably losing but let's
see maybe there's between maybe see it
to try to put pressure on this pot I
guess a clean idea or yeah let's say
I'll just go clean a Fiat I guess it's
really now do I have 94 here no I don't
so I'll play rough eh
I'll trade I'll trade nobody's got 94
whoops
[Music]
ever he chucked everything I'm way up on
the clock so repudiate feel that she's
six oh but now I'm 94 gone I mean yes he
can take I guess then I have six again
hit the pawn on d5 d6 I'll just play g6
and g7 I don't really want to give him a
draw here so that's why I'm gonna keep
playing keep playing on he was just g6
created square for my King now I feel
like we're me too or something
[Music]
ninety-eight Kaplan 95 yeah let's play
95 let's let's let's go for the victory
let's go for the victory 90
oh but DISA oh he can play DISA or oh I
forgot that night eeks d7 was shocked
it's check on d7 I forgot that it was
shocked
yikes okay I mean I'll still went on
time because he's not a fast blitz
player but not not very good to say the
least
he'll take
I have five hit the rook
Asics
[Music]
ha ha ha ok that was stupid
all right you guys so how's it going
everybody I am back again the car with
your grand mastery car oh I was trimming
a little bit earlier on my channel some
of you are watching watching me play
earlier some of you guys are obviously
just coming to the channel now so today
is gonna be the sub Saturday event so if
you wish to play me today you you need
to be a subscriber of the chess comm
channel so twitch TV slash just the
channel we're on right now so it's just
gonna be three hours of five-minute
blitz playing everybody who's a
subscriber so alright you guys so I
think I think chess Bay and Azusa
massive matki are gonna be the two
people in charge of putting together the
queue for everybody who wishes to play
me today so I'll just wait for them to
let me know what the list is and take it
from there okay so the Q is milori a so
I will play meloria to start let's play
efore alright let's play Knight up three
play a Sicilian so ii 6s play d4 or
takes play 94 93 probably Bishop d3
maybe 93 at some point
thanks for streaming Yukari you're very
welcome Ginty TV so yes if you guys wish
to play me in your subscribers of the
channel just I think you're supposed to
write what your user name is in the chat
and trust me auntie will be taking care
of all that so 95 let's play 94 okay
there should be seven
let's just play c4 here kick the knight
out of d5 probably put a knight on d6
black spawns are pretty kind of
misplaced here and I'm gonna put a
knight on d6 and should be good RPG 350
says I want to play please but wife has
made my dinner please put me in the
queue for later yeah I think they can do
that I could have some fun with Bishop
e3 c5 96 I think I'll just play
traditional 96 whole tray
yeah check comm channel does only have
328 subscribers a lot less than most of
the other major channels
well like eric has a bunch I've as much
I think the main thing is the chest comm
channel it's more broadcasts than
anything so anyway oh he's not a sub saw
on the subscription right so you just
click if you look to the right of above
the channel you'll see there's no there
should be green hard and a green get the
sub if you click the down button I'll
get the sub you can you scroll down and
you can you can click Subscribe so fish
bait 6 will play v3 protect the pawn on
c4 here yeah oh yeah yes our our PD 352
be a sum of this channel not my channel
actually to be a sub of the chess
channel itself not a not not uh not not
my channel which would be GM Hikaru so
this channel the chat channel itself so
anyway yes let's have some fruit to UM
at it more its opening me back
somebody's subscribe and I didn't see it
I think someone just did subscribe clean
b8 yeah let's go some nuts calm yeah
more more more food I'm gonna be eating
the dried apricots Queen be a sluggish
way 3 it actually not is I mean dried
apricots so yeah ok taste I'll take with
a [__] um
maybe Bishop c5 his pieces are very bad
here he has all these pawns on the white
squares and the bishop has no access
because the pawns restrict it and even
here he can never open up the diagonals
as Bishop on c5 is really really
powerful I might have some chips - I've
got these lovely Tina watch that's it
amazing as well so a pretty good
probably shakes five maybe rookie to
work d1 and try to put pressure on Conde
seven thank you at planean for
subscribing with twitch prime Bon
Appetit Thank You class 4a - although +4
- that sounds like a German handle Nadia
not a not a on French handle a purple
and yellow board would be nice that'd be
interesting I've never actually I don't
think they have that theme that would be
interesting so okay so bishop about
three I'm probably gonna play work D to
work two one meloria is holding in the
sense that he's not getting blown off
the board but positionally he's pretty
much lost cuz his pieces are so bad here
this bishop is stuck behind small pawns
this Bishop on c5 dominates her sorry
dominates
[Music]
there we go okay so now you said I don't
play Brooke T to work do you won this
Bishop is just stuck behind stuck behind
a wall pawns here and I'm gonna put a
lot of pressure on this backward pawn
and d7 it's a true we got here for three
hours yes I will be here for three long
hours today you guys so if you aren't
already go ahead and sub and there to
claim he can play see if I have to open
the diagonal then I've got this should
be six and he's gonna lose some rooks
Gokul says he cards for three hours and
he has to leave before at night yep
pretty much is the bubblegum board
something from is a bubblegum I just saw
it calm it's a bubble bubble gum board
something from four at night no I don't
think so I leave Bishop e6 if the rook
he's gonna go rook c8 I'll go rook d7 I
clean en subscribed yes you can
challenge me just write your username on
chess calm in the chat and trust me
we'll add you trust Bay or Azusa massa
mati will add you to the queue I mean I
feel like I'm just gonna say Z zoom a
Sumati all day long after after seeing
that legendary legendary Spragg eclipse
it's a Bishop c5 AVP 94 says will I turn
the fortnight yes the sport net would be
on Alexandra's channel I said I said it
perfectly zzmatt sumati oh it's masa
masa masa it's z zu masa masa masa song
it's my Psalm it's I was saying z zu
matzah ma not z zu matzah mine masa mom
sorry I work do you want I'll take
potato gun - you okay
this is completely winning all this
takes upon officers and go f7 king c2
I'm probably f7 next move
I can just take the rook here is there a
quick meet or not I don't I guess this
is just a quickest one it's just mean -
I just take the bishop promote the pawn
checkmate thank you play the Gras for
subscribe on the tier 1 sub alright
so I guess next up in the Q max Milnes
there is Maxie max a very good mod from
Poland simply d4 I think he likes the
London system so I'm not gonna let him
play the London system miles SGG
Karthik's is a game that was a good game
on if you're gonna play that opening
though you need to study the theory very
heavily because if you don't know
exactly what you're doing you're gonna
end up losing very quickly like you have
to understand what the pawns let's see
it's it's an e6 what you're playing for
which is dynamics and you do stuff
really really quickly
[Music]
alright it's my move sorrow can io6
let's play as a Benoni
Bishop g7 next move what's that move up
move out to us today he cards using
glass pieces and icc board it's his
choice expand your mind and enjoy a new
theme exactly that's the spirit totally
move ah thank you for that I'll put b5
mmm-hmm 94 yeah so basically here why
it's undeveloped and I want to play
Queen 85 and use this bishop on the long
diagonal to create threats more arrows
arrows arrows arrows right the Queen b3
I think there's clean eight five truck
now a king has problems Queen d2 is
coming this might be a puzzle rush very
shortly okay now I think White's just
lost cuz I can take and play Queen C 3
and win material right away so I'm just
gonna win a bunch of material here now I
take the rook
Flemish basics tonight be six if tons of
loose in a row do we all get adopted
that'd be pretty funny eh five playoff
five here probably he'll trade
I'll take however lost a sub-game not in
the the two that I've done on my own
channel I've not lost a game so Bishop
e2 all take the pawn on tv5 he can't
take so the pin on the King all right we
go again let's play howdy 5,000 you guys
also need to actually challenge me as
well in chess calm so let's say our JUCO
stunts do I remember Cuernavaca I think
on my string yesterday or the day before
I was actually wearing a Mexico shirt
Cuernavaca shirt in fact so yeah I do
remember corner vodka very fondly I was
a great tournament there and I enjoy JD
five the jury gave me a scar on the
first up Sunday correct JD fives I'll
take an play d5 or a five I think I'll
click d5 or 96 let's play 96 actually so
I guess I can play e5 I don't know why
you didn't take the pawn to d4 oh wait
sorry no I'm sorry it's his move I
proved ninety-six Stuber says he
challenged me I did not see your
challenge stub us I don't see your
challenge service you need to reach
challenge me I don't see your challenge
or those just as eyebrows or does he
always have have have one brow raised
this is how my eyebrows look normally I
mean I wish I could do the rock look but
I can't I can't do the rock look that
would be awesome if I could do that but
I can't do it
look that would be awesome the chest
sport like if someone like the rocket
play destiny could raises raises eyebrow
raised his eyes and the eyebrow the way
he does when he used to Russell that'd
be the best thing ever to do during a
chess game okay stop if I see your
challenge now so I will play you knocks
game do I've red ball in the cup no I do
not have Red Bull I have a nice hot cup
of coffee
man this playlist is so bad I keep I
keep getting hit with these ads on
YouTube it's rough castles all Castle I
can do the rock with one eye up and cut
the other yeah I'll play push base six
here try to play on this diagonal
I've got good bishops here ah nice it's
in b4 i can play rook c8 and rook b8 and
d4 OCA idea to play d4 try to win the
knight on c3 here i think that's pretty
much GGO if the knight loose I just take
95 is a very creative move I can just
take the knight because the bishop and
the rook protect each other but I'll
just play some play and just take on a
c2 can you smell what The Rock is
cooking ah isn't that how it goes I'll
play Brooke c1 Bishop d2 and a b6
or I can just trade rooks and take the
night on v6 as well I guess I get them
in that wrestling mood I'm trying to run
right my childhood when I actually
watched a little bit of WWE yeah I mean
I'm sure someone someone can find it but
yeah
Playworks c8 probably v e4 or just wish
me to looks good probably work c2 next
move
[Music]
yeah you need yourself of this channel
you guys if you're in order to play me
today just click subscribe on the chest
channel and you'll be able to play me
today it's a sub Saturday but no I
normally do sub Sundays on my channel
but I'm doing a sub Sun a special sub
Saturday on the chest comm channel so
it's a good opportunity to to click
subscribe to watch me play get a chance
to play me and just just enjoy enjoy the
shots Rowley so bishop d1 I'll take the
bishop
okay called over p2 let's let's let's
let's make Harry the the hero let's go
eat
let's see do I get the Queen no no I
don't get the cleanup girls make a Chuck
works it too oh we do won't be solvent
that would not be very good okay let's
play stop this I'll play E for Knight c3
if you takes I'll take back
clean out three tasters take back the
Queen
so c6 I'll play d4 I guess I'll play
Queen d3 Knight f3 next next move so I
asked how do i how do I study theory and
chess mainly you just use chess programs
to look at all the openings you use like
chat space or I think there's justice
assistant trainer as well so a couple
programs but mainly it's just looking at
the game seeing what everyone is playing
and trying to try to come up with new
ideas
so let's play c4 Oh play b3 rook e8 I'll
play Bishop e2 crank iron says I saw you
braiding Lex belt house the other day do
you poker yourself I do play poker
occasionally not that much because it's
very hard to play online and going to
the casino to play live and just play
playing cash games just sitting at the
table for hours hours and hours on end
and just folding over and over until you
get hands it's a not a not as enjoyable
as playing online where you get so many
more hands and much quicker so
plain I'd be five so let's play D for
hit the night on c5 yeah I wish I could
play poker if poker was legal in the UI
still I would definitely stream poker 97
let's play twister d4 hit the Queen
actions the Queen moves he loses the
bishop and he can't he can't move to c6
my bishop covers it and the knight also
covers a square my knight is protected
so black is losing material here so I'll
take the rook can't play cards but can
buy machine guns in the supermarket well
let's not get into politics you guys I I
agree with the sentiment but let's not
get into politics right now so Bishop f6
I'll take to take the rook like Queen 84
hit the night on a d7 I'm actually just
gonna sack material here he'll probably
take with the queen of the night if he
takes with the night at roof d1 just
winning more material and now Queen d7
and Queen d8 is just winning so I'll
click Queen d7 maybe just Queen d8 just
trade that should be southern I guess
and then let's just make a queen
let's make it clean I'll take and Chuck
Nate that's me alright let's play face
chess go for it go for a gopher the hero
let's see what he wants to play I'll
play d5 vivvy takes I'll take back with
the Queen
a queen in five the queen looks like a
sad frog well I decided to try something
different hate ropes bud how's it going
I hope you have a good afternoon I
figure I'll use some different pieces
today Keith on skis as I want to play
sorry Keith aunty you need to be a
subscriber of the channel to play I'll
play Bishop b4 here I'll take play
Knight d7 Knight f6 a pretty good
position this is a standard Scandinavian
here Oh Keith Oski is a sub oh okay I
didn't realize that alright fair enough
learn something new every day
[Laughter]
Liam says yeah I do i I don't actually I
don't like I see Liam shows his
challenger actually so anyway we'll see
it's all play Knight b6 I guess I could
trade I could also just cow so I think
all those cows to play a solid end game
actually now I see your challenge lamb
shot I see your challenge so I see it
now so you are in good shape
okay now h4 play cheese six
so I'll play cheese 6 and 95 I guess
next move why do my music just stop
someone's calling me I can't pick up the
phone I'm obviously very very busy
playing you guys so sorry about the
music temporarily stopping but what to
do okay I'll take on c4 I'll put the
knight on d5 I guess so the next set of
games that I'm gonna play it's gonna be
it'll be
Clank aah Clank aah Liam says go cool
and Keith on ski and how hard h up those
are the next five games so if you're one
of those guys you'll get the you'll
you'll get that's gonna be the next five
games so just hang tight you guys will
get your shot very shortly so I'll take
I'll take back okay yeah Sookie I see
your challenge as well you're also on
the list I see your challenge to see
your you're gonna get a game as well
did I just hang upon an a7 for some
reason I think I accidentally did oh
well he didn't take it though so I'll go
a 5 it's probably 195 then I'll go like
94 or night C for me to protect the paw
and control the e5 square great outpost
on c4 so pretty pretty pretty good
rook c7 that's a good move too I'll play
my ep 6 try to win the pawn in a 4
oh the music just stopped when they let
me pull up the playlist again night a
for maybe a little start over from the
beginning maybe eight age three to stop
the meat okay so I'll play a four maybe
I'll try to go rupee one and I think I'm
getting check me here fee fie foe fum I
smell checkmate on each one so yeah I do
that just game over but why can't stop
Roque Chuang says pawn supports the
night in the night supports the h1
square so why is just getting made to
here right he resigns let's play
kalenkov clan Cove is actually 24
hundreds of very strong flare let's keep
playing
a bit of everything today I'll play a
carro con this game he takes I'll take
back hopefully c4 I'll play Knight f6
and cheese six I guess there should be
seven play Bishop g7 there should be two
all Castle Hill Castle play knight c6
here take shots of Jimmy Carter thank
you sir you actually did quite well you
got some good drawing chances in that
game he plays h3 I could take and play
b6 like it also sleep b6 right away
oh and actually I see a challenge from
Angus fishermen now so Angus I see your
challenge - so you're you're you're
gonna get a game as well so I might
actually play you next games I think
your your highest up on the queue and
you've been having I think there were
any issues with your challenges so
you'll get the next game I'll play OCA
I'll take and play Knight a5 if he takes
with a pawn I'll play night before 95 so
yeah it's just hang in there and and I
will play you next game yeah this is
sub-sub this is for subs of this channel
not subs of me on them on my channel so
you have to be a sub of the chest comm
channel in order to in order to
challenge me today
garam chai 94 says this is this is uh
this is what I love about the internet
getting to play a GM on a nice Saturday
morning yeah it is it is a Saturday
morning
Maurice notices how do you manage to
memorize all the different Pete's just
years and years of practice really years
and years I mean just lots and lots of
practice over over the years so I'll
play Bishop efore and queen bee 584
awfully [__] takes e4 hey are you one
of my favorite champs thanks for
consistently coming on in playing chess
against us you're very welcome DG purist
now this guy's doing well but there is
one problem here which is he's got some
weak pawns so I can play push page six
of each X I can go King g7 defy the e5
and then I win the pawn in III and this
is the one weakness the bishop is not
great on p2 and he's got these weak
pawns in the center so he plays King up
- good move all Tyrone and Chuck think
I'll play Queen d5 next move hit all the
hit all the pawns
there's Quincy 3 all right so I guess
I'll just go back well we'll do this
little actually why did I go back I was
suit because now no I shouldn't have
done this this is kind of silly I should
not have played it like this if d5 I can
just take Quincy eight access some
mistakes now I can go King g7 on d5 IV v
and now I take the pawn on e3 next move
[Music]
so I'll take the pawn on e3 for cleany
one
maybe check Queen d2 cleaning off to -
let's check me this guy was doing fine
in this game he just should not have he
should not have played played Queen uh
you should not have played this Queen
see a movie just waited with King up -
and Queen d2 he would have been doing
completely fine so that's that's what he
should have done that would have been uh
that would have been he could have just
held the position that way as opposed to
the way you play it so I'm gonna play
Angus now let's play the throne POW ski
knight of three probably III
[Music]
ninety-two probably Bishop d3 or Bishop
450h before I guess both are fine so I'm
gonna play 20 something's wrong you want
to play e5 but now he just gave me this
extra tempo to get my Bishop here and
the bishop also prevents e5 as like
control squared three times I could have
told monopoly Queen see it before he did
right yeah but if I did that then in
theory I'm just playing against myself
right bone cloud one I'll throw in a
bond thought some work for you guys
somewhere okay let's play e4 if he takes
I take back and then I take with a
bishop now I have sex Bishop d3 probably
c4 pretty pretty normal so cargo Queen
e2 what yes well it's my choice I feel
like doing something different you know
it gets tiring using the same green
board using my black black boards like
sometimes you you you want to express
yourself you want to like do something
different rather than the same thing
over and over again so that's why the
colors are different and everything is a
little bit a little bit well it's just
it's a little bit different you gotta
have some fun sometimes besides be
careful you say the board is bad you're
someone that someone's gonna come after
you I think if you say that too often so
I'll play with d1 is 95 I guess
[Music]
a 97 Oakland Queeny for I don't know
about 97 I think the night was better
just staying there um he really needs to
play for c5 to open bag ooh f5 whoo
that's very very bold now of course the
problem is a problem is is that now on
this pawn on e6 is very weak he could
have just put the knight back on f6 and
tried to open the diagonal now he's
gonna have issues with this pawn on him
on e6 for the rest of the game and now
there's the other problem that after c5
the bishop is stuck behind the pawn so
he really should not have played it
quite like this because now he is now
there from now there are problems for
block definitely dr. Milwaukee says he
car how do you think your subconscious
or your so your subconsciousness should
be subconsciousness helps helps in
bullet shots I think it's just I mean
like it's just intuition it's pure
calculation pure knowledge of
understanding where the pieces are going
and that's what makes a huge difference
the board is fine if the pieces that
look ugly be careful be careful go cool
be careful be careful let's play Bishop
e2 James rookie f7 says I keep it real
this guy has huge flaws in this game
everybody has flaws there yeah I don't
know if you're talking about me or my
opponent but everybody's got flaws I can
play nice before I can just play p4
protect the pond so that I don't lose it
ever lose threatening to win the pawn on
can I switch to bubblegum okay all right
you guys you want it you want it can you
can you dig it can you dig it here we go
here we go here we go here we go
and voila voila what see voila
9f8 let's play Knight to c4
[Laughter]
okay now I can put the knight on to you
so excite suppose I can also put like
Bishop after even anarchy one idea of
issue after idea idea 96 upon us maybe
hanging a three as well
Bishop h5 - okay go back go back go back
go back
all right you guys all right you guys um
there you go
how does it look now how does it feel
now okay oh go Knight a5 hit the fish
bump e7 I'm fishing about three next
move hit the pawn at c6 now yeah so
we'll see what he wants to do next move
um but this is a very creature so I'm
gonna go Queen b3 me to play for d5 at
some point Liam says let's please back
to bubblegum Oh Liam did I accept your
challenge yet or knocks I don't see a
challenge from you at the moment I'll
play d5 he'll take and then I'll take
back I guess actually yeah I don't see
your challenge Liam says thank you
silent defender oh six for Riesling
three months in a row I will take
complete g3 actually why did I do that I
was just supposed to take i blundered I
just wondered - Pau for no reason but I
saw him doing pretty well since Bishop
was bad I still get a blockade his pawns
he's got this real big ugly back for
pawn on on on e6 overnight be three
nights or 94k CFL's as I hate to say it
but the viewer count went up with the
with the bubblegum board
[Laughter]
yeah there it is Liam says so actually
you've been waiting a while too so I'll
give you the next game so takes and I'll
take the rook on e7 magician 531 sets
after seeing that you weren't online on
your twitch I was pleasantly surprised
to find you here
hey magician hope you're having a great
Saturday Saturday morning great start to
the it is a long weekend
somebody told me was a long weekend is
it's a long weekend right or not I think
it's a long weekend so 96 hit the rook
on a on ei yeah I guess I play 94 if he
takes tonight I take the rook are you
couldn't take my rook is on I would when
it's clean on f6
let's go b5 c6 c7 c8 make it Queen play
c6 of takes I just take back that's a
check I will pre move see take speeds up
in here okay alright let's play the Liam
shoves patience is one is born with the
car that will be tonight it I believe
six o'clock Eastern time so I'll be
playing on Alexandra stream so that
would be a twitch on TV / Alexandra
bowties I believe if I'm not mistaken so
that'll be at 6 o'clock eastern Pacific
so about three hours from now
[Music]
so Queen v3 I'll take me take the take
back
986 try to win the pawn on d4 Knight
before now threatened Knight see 2
cloths for two says now it's gone the
rest of my life analyzing this game do
you play professionally yes I do James
rook f7 I play charles professionally my
next event will be starting on February
20th I'll be playing in st. Louis
Missouri USA or chasse mizura
USA against yon for so christophe
doo-dah is a young polish kid we playing
a rapid and blitz match and then I will
be playing I'll be playing the US
Championship starting out round mark 18
to about April 1st so that's that's my
schedule that's a pretty pawn I think
you live in st. Louis Wow actually view
the chance go to you should drop by the
chess club in the Central West End if
you have a chance what am i eating I'm
eating these simply seven kena walk
ships sea salt they are simply
incredible what can I say about them
just best thing ever
simply amazing simply amazing and that's
probably the thing that's great about
these ships is they taste amazing
they're not too flavor but the whole bag
is like 400 calories so it's really
really good
play 94-98 off to
also the other good thing is like you
eat the whole bag of chips and and you
have squirted calories like you go out
together you know that nice bag of like
Lay's it's like sour cream and onion or
something really bad and you just really
addictive you eat the whole bag it's
like oh look I just ate the whole bag oh
wait that's like 1,100 calories what do
I just do so yeah we'll play you six
let's play a beat five is 20 a kid and
Chuck for chess no definitely not
hikaru calories shaving potato chips I
mean yeah I get the family get the
family size where I get the family size
bag and that's like even worse no what
do you mean Lay's does more than that
doesn't it I mean I know Pringles do as
well but anyway let's just go for this
play night of three I'll play out this
pretty seven kingi seven Laura Torres
Lord to reassess hi man long time Vic
tan never knew you stream this is
awesome where are you right now right
now I am in Sunrise Florida so I live in
Florida and I mean 20 yeah I mean okay
dude eyes young kid junior I don't
literally mean he oh he's like he's he's
a kid like he could be my son or
something I just mean like he is still
quite young and actually I the one thing
I will say about young y'all one of the
great things about you on Christoph is
that if you saw him play the speech
amateur contest calm I feel like there
are many times his mom would come into
the room after he won the match it was
it was really nice to see so he is still
fairly young but he has a amazingly
talented chess player so I Liberty won
I'll throw a check on b5 probably with
this guy what what Liam trusted wrong
was in the opening yeah he should not
have taken on d4 to see punished until
allowed this whole Queen b6 idea on move
5 and mr. chip Brandt what brand are
they it is simply 7 is the brand simply
subpoena wash up sea salt they have a
couple other flavors now as well but I
really like to see salt ones I mean one
let me see the whole tag guys let's see
the whole bag has yellow back it's like
480 calories I think look over d4 III -
coming alive from the a50 quinoa Oh only
you could say although I have to say to
give you on lentils are one of my
favorite things in the world - I love
legumes so lentils are amazing
I'll go eat to make a queen he resigns
let's play the go cool it's play Knight
f6 so I'm like my sub my regular sub
Sundays were there I get hit with a
million challenges since the challenge
list is a little bit it's not completely
out of control I will try to follow the
actual Q as much as I can today lentils
are amazing anyone who doesn't like
legumes well there's something wrong
with you what doesn't kill you is an
edible that is also very true I'll play
cheese 6f3 let's play Bishop g7
you just like saying a legumes legumes
legumes
goodnight these six probably I'll take
and played fish about five or Bishop g4
I think I'll play Bishop g4 here I think
I think I can take ninety six lentils
are dope lentils are the greatest thing
ever there's some people I know I don't
think he's in the chapter it's a good
friend of mine who's like he's like he
thinks lentils are the worst thing ever
and I just want to smack him across the
face
so castles I will just take work f3 I'll
castle yeah lentils are the best thing
ever lentils really are amazing I'll
play f6 I don't think he's in the chat
actually let me see he's in the chat I
don't think he is no he's not he's not
but I mean yeah there's a good friend of
mine he's like he thinks I'm insane for
liking lentils and he made a whole long
post on him on Facebook the other day
because someone else was saying lentils
are great that he was losing his mind
okay d5 I just take the pawn this was
slightly wrong I think he should have
played uh he should have played let's go
back a few moves
yeah after Bishop g4 I think he was
supposed to play Age 3 so that when I
take him take with the Queen and then
get the quick development with Bishop
III in castles long wears in the game
he's kind of he's stuck here like after
f6 the whole center is just very very
brittle everything's kind of hanging all
over the place okay for xsplit g5 I
could also take this actually Bishop h6
looks good too rookie three I will take
I'll just take the pawn on e5 he'll take
bathroom hon I would assume this table
relay is so annoying well there's not
much I can do about this action is not
my overlay this is the chest comm
overlay for sub Saturday I could change
the board in pieces but that's the only
thing that I can change
BJ chose oh I like the set in board
color Oh King in shape yeah PGH maybe go
check this chord I sent you a quick
message uh eggplant is great too like
eggplant I wonder why they always use
different words like does somebody know
why do they call eggplant aubergine in
the UK but in the u.s. it's it's AG
plant because aubergine obviously is
eggplant in French but but I don't
understand why in the UK they they call
it an aubergine as well when whereas I
could just call it eggplant like we do
in the US
yeah aubergine is French I know
aubergine is French well okay but I mean
I get it I get it but like in an
english-speaking country when you like
we call it eggplant why do they call it
aubergine in the you
where they speak English - oh it's just
aubergine in the EU as a whole
okay they try to sound fancy like it's
not I mean I guess yeah aubergine sounds
fancy I'm like you know good old fish
and chips or you know like haggis or
like all that other good like classic UK
type of stuff so 96 I can play with da
to hit the night and probably take on a
3 pint a pint of beer eh yeah I know
it's called aubergine I thought is like
but like in England they also speak
English it's you know Germany I
understand or like the you know Sweden
where you all everyone has a different
language I get it but it's just weird
that in the UK where they also oh that's
a free Brooke isn't it am i blind
yeah I just take can I read the next
five people I will play okay I will play
haul vard let me check the I'll try to
keep to the to the cue as much as I can
I will play all hard Keith on ski okiya
go go savage and horse night 57 those
will be the next five people that I will
play so that's the next five people go
to a savage - you're you're gonna be
there will be three people playing
before you but I speak American not
English alright let's play up five Queen
d4
that was just an interesting thing that
I thought was a little bit funny
I guess just rookie a tricky one
how far representing Norway yes indeed
indeed so age three throw in a track
make a Queenie five checkup play cheerio
Queen d6 is batter puzzle rush there
goes the Queen bye-bye
alright let's play Hull bard H up and
that came actually other in the opening
you should've played Age 3 push left
three Queen f3 Bishop e3 and just
counseled long that was the mistake
allowing me to get but she takes out
throwing castles which is not not how it
should have gone so let's have some fun
and play a very well in a very romantic
style in this game
Oh Mona oh my king did she three fat
grill says or yeah fat girl says you
were so insanely good and to eat quinoa
yes I do and I'm gonna run my king up to
g3 play this in a truly romantic style
run the king up play like Knight h3 I
guess or Bishop d3 is fine too I think I
[Music]
can play 92 or Knight h3 I think I'll
play 92 here our support the center a
little bit more on everything just the
the Knights are very good here as well
so happy 5 will table to F pawn so h6 I
click Queen c2 I can even play Knight a
fort here put a lot of pressure on spawn
at you 696 of the threat maybe Queen c2
and shock in 96 and this King is very
Airy and the G sucks in h7 scores are
very loose here
why is it called romantic so I should
say it's not something you get to do
every day where you get to just run your
king up you move your king up to g3 in
the opening it's just not something that
happens frequently so I'll play Queen b3
here Oh Google establish house we need a
bond cloud yes there will be a bond tub
but I mean are you encouraging me to
play it against you because you're like
there's there only like three people
before you so maybe you're encouraging
me to play it against you I don't know
well it's a person running the King
because you want to get quick
development an attack on the H of G
files generally it doesn't always work
but that's generally what you want guess
I'll play this would be one Chesky says
don't bond cloud me I think it would
work better versus me than a normal
opening I think I will blonde cloud you
thought maybe
okay let's trade the Brooks ago Queen d2
hit the night on b4 maybe sac on ax
maybe just bring the other work to the C
files well I'll actually just preemies
gonna obviously move the Queen on the
king is a fighting piece yes it is
actually
of course I don't think I see your
challenge at the moment so it's not a
big deal since there are three people
ahead of you still but you will want to
reach Alan shortly because I don't see
the challenge right now I've got [__]
beat let's have some fun I mean I'll
sack this probably doesn't work but why
not let's have some fun rather than just
win in a very boring way silver tool 84
says you're the John mount of the chess
world well maybe my voice isn't as good
it's not like and here like this line
then like he pancake the pancake the
defensive defensive lineman here and
because of that the halfback was able to
run all the way up the field I let's
play Knight g5 push page sevens the idea
the only reason I know some of the John
Madden sayings is because I used to play
Madden EA Madden or was itwas is what it
was what mad and
I fell whatever the game was so I used
to play that a bit so I'm slightly
familiar with some of the some of the
phrases I guess I can play queen out six
I can all speak g6 maybe pretty closer
than that oh just a puzzle Russians
puzzle rush baby puzzle rush night h7
jisuk gg checkmate you lose he resigns
oh very sad okay all right sorry
actually Danny AK oh I forgot about
Danny echo so I'll play him first I
forgot since he's been waiting for a
while too so so it'll be the same word
it'll be Keith on ski okiya and gogo
savage and then a horse Knight 57
that'll be the that'll be the order
sorry go go savage I know you were
waiting but this guy was in the queue
and I his challenges were coming and
vanishing so what do I want to play
let's have fun let's let's have fun
today I never played Matt I mean there
was another football game that was
really good that I used to play way back
in the day at the arcade I think it was
uh was it like NFL Blitz or something
from like the 90s I can't remember right
off but I think was NFL Blitz it's the
one where you can like you can like
slant you can like body slam somebody
basically when you tackle them I think
it was NFL Blitz I think it was NFL
Blitz I think that's the that's the game
and that was just hilarious to play that
in casino or actually not a casino at
the arcade but there was an arcade at I
think one of the casinos in Vegas went
when I was very young um think we should
be to hit the rook on h8 uh oh did was
Magnus a soup a question about alpha0
like am i alpha zero
yeah Blitzen where you can like slam
them on the ground and everything right
yeah I think it was yeah I'll play
Bishop c4 catch catch have any decency
car when you come into Russia I will
probably be in Moscow for the fede Grand
Prix and um I think it's in May I think
it's in late May
I think I'll be in Moscow in May if
you're in Moscow that's where I'll be
face justice arcades rest in peace yeah
I know it's a shame our case just don't
exist the way they used to I used to
love going to the arcades there was this
arcade near where I grew up in New York
it was called sport time USA I don't
know if it was a chain or not but that's
a free pawn I take the rook but it was
it was great they had all kinds of games
I mean I used to love going to the
arcade however it says most of my
opening there sort of just played nine
takes d4 an Effie I should be good yeah
I mean the line objectively is is fine
for black I just wanted to make it make
it creative and play something different
but you're you're completely right so go
but about three pinball is alive and
well pin balls another I haven't played
pinball in so long I used to love
playing pinball as well so I'll play c4
oh did the music stop well I wasn't
actually paying attention I think music
stopped they'll start the I'll start the
playlist again in a second go back to
discord
[Music]
viii i guess i'll play rugby one night
of three BGH says i would love to get a
pinball machine my wife would leave me
but it might be worth it Oh totally dude
combo machines are the best that Dark
Knight says who played Street fire I
love Street Fighter 2 another classic
game from my childhood
Danny EKKO is playing really well
actually he's playing he's playing very
very solid game thus far so I'll flick
who should be 7th Street Fighter is the
best game ever
pretty much I don't know how you can't
not love a street fighter play 90 5 hit
the Queen one cycle so Queenie 700 let's
go Bishop b4 here chess pace says miss
pac-man pac-man it's my best game
outside it just pac-man is my best game
by miles say I don't like my position at
all this game I've got a bad position I
guess I'll play Bishop d2 keep an eye on
this a5 font here
pack pack man yeah I mean Pac Man is
just the best as another great game it's
the it's my best game by far like by far
on the slope version I think I I mean I
think I played the regular regular fast
version but I could always get into the
high levels pretty pretty pretty
routinely as long as it Joey stick
wasn't wasn't terrible pinball is
getting expensive these these machines
are becoming diamonds in the rough
Twilight Zone and Adams family can run
close to 11,000 wow really wow I had no
idea that's crazy that's that's crazy I
had no idea that pinball machines were
that
we're not much of a collector's item
these days but I guess they're so rare
now that does make some sense Queen d7
good move up late Queen C for protect
the pawn threatened threatened c6
startin to win upon an a4
[Music]
thank you Paul in Phoenix 19 for
subscribe with a tier 1 sub I think c6
is strong now I know I'm gonna pick up
the pawning 8 for buying back your
childhood gets expensive Touche Touche
indeed it does this is just free pod
yeah pinball machines I mean they used
to be everywhere I remember also no no
area LTO xcr I'm not married um pinball
machines
yeah nice cup where'd I get it oh you
mean this one this one this Cup I got
this Cup when I was it's um it's like
it's like first nation art from from
Canada so I got it at a I think I got it
at the gift shop for the sea to sky
gondola and Squamish British Columbia um
but yeah pinball machines I remember
like when I played the World Youth
Championship in an aural pace of Spain
oh what's going on so play Alexa play
Spotify oh wait Alexa stop
Alexa stop so I was about to just play
Spotify Alexa stop
Alexa stop
[Music]
there we go
better okay one second you guys seven oh
I just wondered upon and c6 what am i
doing
[Music]
what's wrong Spotify today well I can't
actually play Spotify because we're on
the chest channel so I have to play a
copyright free music at the moment
that's the main thing
I just yeah I just wonder this pawn for
no real good reason
Thank You Carl oh thank you
Carl Sagan fan for subscribe at twitch
Prime now I just take the queenside
fishing key one here at the end and
thank you I di manatee for subscribing
with twitch Prime I think I just go king
off one
[Music]
Bishop g3 King e2 and now I'm just gonna
win the game pretty quickly so all right
so it's Keith Antioquia and then gogo
savage is over the next three games so
key for all right
oh sorry I did the wrong word or
whatever it's wrong word but it'd still
be it'll be Keith on ski and then go go
savage and that work just please let's
play e5 this time that's been I see six
I guess Bishop c5 looks good maybe
Knight f6 I guess I'll play d5 Alexa
stop I'll take on e4 1894 just castles
that's these next bishop t5 if the Queen
I'm gonna go Knight d4 now he takes a
knight I take the [__] punchy - and he
moves the rook I take Wow
he moves the rook and I take that with
the pawn and I have rookie eight winning
the Queen on you two
[Music]
so you gotta did I like the Matrix
movies I like the first movie quite a
bit um night of 5 just take the rope
Queen G for what assess mistakes tha I
the matrix movies I like the first one I
thought the second and third movies were
pretty mediocre to be honest I didn't I
thought I didn't like the storyline it
felt it felt contrived like they were
just trying to make more money
um versus the original one where it felt
like the original one was great but the
two and three it just felt like a
contrived storyline to make the make the
trilogy continue or to you know get more
money for two more movies so I'll take
I'll play were create cleanings for I
will take and play which you want to
take the Brooklyn 881 Lauder is greater
than all other movies yeah I mean I have
a I have a big soft spot for Lord of the
Rings I've read I read the books many
times so okay so Keith on skis next play
E for 903 what genre do you read I read
a bit of everything I like I like stuff
on like politics and like healthcare
type things which is pretty very very
heavy reading I like reading some sci-fi
not a lot I also like reading mysteries
and thrillers let's is there a novelty
let's see it has every movement played
in this position before let's try a new
movie let's play b3 here
so b3 I'll click Queen d2 which would be
to next move try to castle quickly on
the Queen side I guess I'll take and
play Bishop b2 probably f3 and castles
[Music]
okay so II 500 causal clicking b1 so
King be one if you council have 95 here
goes especially east six so now I can
start trying to attack with after h3
maybe even out for makes sense try to
open up this long diagonal here yeah for
let's like clean off for me if there
should be two chief where H was coming
here as well so it's pretty good
position
Queenie five that's a reasonable move
but I don't really like it cuz now his
queens in the line of fire on this
diagonal play h3 chief for now I've got
95 and he's got some issues you can play
queen d8 but I think I just take and
take on d6 and it's a pretty bad
position for block here did I see that
table base one that Lila managed to lose
against stock which I haven't been
following that magic close so a couple
of people asked me if I would do some
commentary on it and I wasn't wasn't I
haven't really seen much but I'll
definitely take a look at the game so
Queen h4 hits the bond I think just
Bishop the d3 looks good
[Music]
so a father to play for I guess so he
never ever bought her something big like
a rook or something yeah very rarely do
I blender blender pieces that's what
happens if you play a lot of chess you
got fairly good I mean I can't really
help it
okay so c5 I guess I'll play you now for
try to trade the Queen's put fish bump
d5 maybe belly five Bishop b4 as well
[Music]
Queenie so I'm gonna play d5 of c-4 I
can always just take I can also go
Queenie for try to win the pawn on h7
[Music]
rook b8 I can play Bishop b5 I think why
not and actually over on the Russian guy
so I'll be right back
[Music]
mosqitos Lucio Rachel Colorado Rockies
hoodie what a god yeah this was a gift
from a friend of mine for for my
birthday in December so I'm yeah I know
I'm I'm winning here cuz I've got all
these extra pawns Chuck Queen d3 Queen C
I guess I can even play Queen C 4 why
not I've got all these extra pawns even
if I take double pawns there's no way I
can stop everything here so guys got
rook d5 I missed that I'll put you on
trespass says it's not 85 and sunny
there where is there Colorado in Denver
no it's not 85 there but uh yeah Denver
is a great great city I love Denver or
oh no we're talking about Texas okay
we're talking about Texas so we're
talking about Florida we're we're
talking about Levy said he got off the
plane it was 70 and sunny and taxes and
the angel angels were singing
and he almost wept chest because you're
wearing a big warm hoodie in Florida
well why not
okay now I'll play the Queen out three
to try to hit the rook hit the Queen and
hit the pawn I've got three connected
passed pawns they're just going up the
board so he really doesn't want to trade
the Queens but he doesn't really have a
choice either cuz that sees a free rook
alright let's play go go Savage I'll
play e4 so the next couple games are
gonna be a horse night Thomas Dobson
chest guy ten twelve if he's still here
which I don't see him at the moment
Attila terzo and then Ibrahim of a one
one one one one so I'll play Bishop c4
it's how the end yes let's play the
Italian opening this game I know there's
some people in the chat who absolutely
loved the Italian opening so I might as
well play it for them pay some pay pay
homage to them Bishop c5 oh please see
three white wizard such a stream made
you want to compete at less events in
general no but I would say that the one
thing is traveling is takes it takes a
lot or it takes a lot of time and maybe
energy is the wrong word but it just it
saps you a lot so it's just it's it's
it's tough pupil Phoenix AZ Wiseman
talks room on its own channel this is a
one one-time deal I'm just doing a sub
Saturday on the trust long Channel today
so normally it would be on my channel
but at the moment it's I'm just doing
this as a bit of a favor for chess comm
play a for traveling also as turbulences
you've been flying an airplane as
turbulence yeah bad that is true too
so I guess I can take and play like work
be one he's got this bat backward pawn
I've got this great square he's also got
double pawns in the e-file Queen b3 is a
huge threat to I think Oh click Queen b3
try to do this so he takes me to lose
this he's also got issues here
maybe Bishop e3 hit the rook on f8 rook
e8 I could play rook e1 at least c4 c5
plays c4 seve blocks I go c5 and I
really just want to force us bishop to
move so I can win this pawn of b7 here
and now he's got these ugly pawns as
well so the main thing that black has
done wrong here is that he took was back
with the knight on c6 in the opening you
should have taken with the pawn if he
had done that he would have been fine
taking what the night was I was uh what
wasn't correct
it's a 94 I can just take I guess and
take the pawn abby's up and play Queen
six here
[Music]
search of 795 so what do I think a
Bitcoin not it not a fan of crypto at
all I think it's a very flawed concept
okay work see Simon I'll go back to b5
here
[Music]
now I'll trade since I'm up upon knees
got I'm up upon I've got a beautiful
night on a c4 square it kind of it hits
hits everything here and I'm up on as
well so this is just the dream is it
three-mile play would be one he'll take
I'll take back sorry not worked before
I'll obviously take on b5
for a thousand viewers why were over
4000 viewers wow that's amazing
um so hitting everything here at Bishop
d6 is a move because it was played she
get to recreate a square for my King
first I've got plenty of time all his
pawns are very weak here so there's no
rush doesn't make the square so don't
get back right in the Edit here with
something works c1 at the end so now
I've always got this king tree to square
because I push let's play an endgame
[Music]
play Rocky 500k 8 now I'll just bring my
king closer and the problem here for
black is also this this pawn at 85 the
rook is tied to this palm permanently
any can never dislodge the brook because
my pond protects the brook on b5 so
there are all kinds of problems from
block here I'll go teeny to play a four
[Music]
in the beginning says please don't say
that just sold my car for for Bitcoin oh
yeah so now I'll go d4
[Music]
King d3 I'm gonna play d5 maybe work p6
me just bring my king over actually
let's go t5 here keep it simple
[Music]
now I can go over chief five so the rook
is perfect here I hit all who all his
pawns are kind of attack but his rookie
now I now I've got the free hand to
bring my king all the way over king b5
is pretty good this rook is amazing here
it's just it's supported by all these
ponds
you can never dislike the brook and now
I'm just gonna bring my king up push
this a upon all the way up the board
it's going a5 king c6 king b7 I'll go
this way instead let's have some fun in
the e6 now I protected look this way or
the pawn this way so can be 7e 78
[Music]
and checkmate all right we go again
let's play force night 57 so basically
the main thing that that uh my opponent
did wrong in that game as far I wished
he was that last one
was he took pinochle the pawn on c6 out
that was the problem
the go game you go again that's become
like the favorite thing everyone always
wants me to say that now even though I
don't think I think very few people here
actually follow xqc I'll play 93 94 this
whole taking play 94 hit the pawn Atilla
terms how are you front yeah Attila
you're you're you're in the middle there
but I see your challenge so you you
definitely are on the list I don't see
challenges from shots got 10 12 or
Ibrahim up I don't take challenges from
either of them at the moment so now I'll
check I will take the pawn on d4 I guess
my queen just to be safe
thank you for youth formula for
subscribing with twitch prime 97 I guess
I'll play Bishop g5 hit the knight on e7
I have 5 I could take and just plop the
Bishop on f6 which I will also do if he
takes I got this really dominating pawn
and then all the dark squares are open
around the King like Queen h4 or even
rook e1 Ricky 7 in the 95 tons of
pressure everywhere here his King is bad
this rook is out of the game he would
like to work to be on like d8 he can't
get it
I'll play Queen c5 check a gameplan he5
here I'll play Knight g5 why not
Thank You Costa 564 for subscribing with
twitch prime levees contractor me yeah
it's all levee on on Lita so I assume
he's in a he's in trouble right now
I'll play Knight g5 and okay let me have
some fun with it you don't have to ruin
it before I even get before he gets the
end thank you for that day geez
[Music]
alright
it's like rookie 7 and night of 7 wow
this is how you destroy Sicilian it's a
beautiful position yeah I mean my
opponent just made a couple of
inaccurate when was gonna play h4 so
that now this rook is permanently dead
he can't ever push the pawn to h4 and
get the rook active commonness that's
the car link your twitch stream
I'm sure move ah can can tell you what
my stream is as well
[Music]
Judy wants to do quick we need to differ
black know I'll show you what yeah this
the his pieces are so bad here even just
takes into work g7 is me so very quickly
you guys I'll play the next name in a
second but just to point out one good
thing someone said isn't Queen b6 good
because of Queen d6 a night raid he once
upon an f6 Queen d6 runs into a puzzle
rush work d1 black can't take the rooks
output the King and shock and after
Queen takes e5 there's rook takes T it
which is made so that's why I went it
worked
so okay let's play Thomas Dobson let's
play French I don't think I've played
any French just yet so let's play the
French
9:06 Davis loves at UNC since legend
himself dude much respect you're like
the greatest of all time thank you thank
you so much play if six takes clean up
six
[Music]
that was a little bit weird
okay c3 I'll play clean b6 so so I guess
I'll just take the pawn on b2 yeah four
thousand people watching yeah it's doing
suspicious night Zack yeah
thank you for it's not exactly the best
move there I can say that without a
doubt okay Chuck I do see your challenge
by the way so so yeah you're up next oh
shucks guy attila torres oh um my bag of
chips all the way it's a chef's guy told
zero and then I tell it tours oh sorry
Ibrahim oh he shows back up a new
diamond
James 177 177 says I love watching Eric
Hanson rage when he plays you yes Eric
does like to rage on it's one of his
most endearing qualities rook d1 I will
take on e4 and Castle let's play a Rick
d8 alright a3 I can play Bishop d7 I'm
probably Bishop e5 knight c6 something
like this and it's pretty good
[Music]
calculate the England gambit I could pro
player I forgot that I need to bond
Claude somebody it's not gonna be trust
it silently chest guys Rob on cloud
somebody soon I forgot I forgot about
that but I long thought somebody
favorite book on geopolitics history I
actually do like some of the some of the
biographies that uh David McCall has
done on so the presidents like his
biography I think you do want on
Benjamin Franklin he definitely did one
of John Adams which was amazing as well
so the both of those books are really
really good
[Music]
Oakland I see six he'll take I'll take
back have I read of people's history of
the United States I have who's up by
people's history I don't think I have a
people's history of the United States
it's oh it's by Howard Zinn oh I've
heard of Howard Zinn but I don't know I
haven't read that book I definitely have
not read that book so I'll go Bishop b6
yeah I definitely not read that book 97
I'll go King h8
yeah I have heard of Howard Zinn but
I've never read the book and yeah he is
he as far to the lot doesn't he anyway
okay a four I'll play rook d8 I guess
hit the King on each on d3 let's see
I'll play a six prevent him from from
going to be five I'll throw on a Chuck I
will take Chuck let's see if I can how
close I can get to it me let's see can I
get it Oh wallah I didn't even have to
make any moves all right let's play
chess guy ten twelve play E for Knight
c3
happen sometimes you sometimes you just
get the urge to pre move what can I say
it happens sometimes you get the pre
move sometimes you get the urge what can
I say sometimes you don't even need to
you don't even need to think or make
moves you just pre move it all just sit
back have a beer relax it's all so easy
sometimes a laugh out loud what was that
[Laughter]
[Music]
google says it's easy to see how you
should play more 30-second goes oh no no
no no no no no more 30-second shots I'm
done with that that's that's just not
just
[Music]
this little castle short your guess
see-through why not
[Music]
maybe just Bishop d6 or maybe even just
Bishop d2 throw is take I'm a little
worried about clean each for actually so
I guess I'll just um no I'll just go
Bishop d2 the Ripper says there is
actually 10 second chess yes I know
there's son ii trust that it will not
touch with a ten-foot pole let's play
rook e1 Knight b6 I'll just go back play
C 4 C 5 maybe point out 3 maybe between
G 4 he wants to go a 4x play 8 3 I could
also just play C 4
I think I let's play a3 he'll play a
four I'll go push me to or you should
play it four at least
what about a 10 second Pole that's a
good one we now 6 I guess I could play
off or I could even get creative with
queen chief where I'm a second exchange
or try to give him a chance
I've got c4 coming up Mike the wops us
at trust me 94 I can't wait to the chest
crew play fortnight fortnight yes we're
playing fortnight later they'll be at 6
o'clock Eastern so I think it'll be I
think it's gonna be I'll be playing
Alexander will be playing chess Pia will
be playing I believe the fourth person
four squads will be Goldust Tori if I'm
not mistaken so that's gonna be that's
gonna be it'll be the four of us so
it'll be three chicks in and I've been a
bad for a night player that's what it'll
be
so g6 meet Bishop c2 I could even cake I
don't like cheese's I think you have
five is strong here yeah I guess a five
why not a 94 is coming here that's kind
of ugly two hours from now no it'll be
but actually a two and a half hours from
now yeah
and it'll be on Alexander boathouses
channel as well and yeah Alec is
basically a pro for time players yeah
you're right on that Gokul out well
maybe he's not a pro but he's he's
pretty freakin good so yes alec is alex
is Alec is a big big star zero winning
chances is that my TV gets Magnus that's
my giving us Magnus isn't it
come please c4 actually I like was
trimming fortnight earlier I think I'm
not mistaken as well so he's gonna have
to go like 97 then c5 or defy this is
pretty ugly for four-block oh he still
is trimming fortnight yeah I didn't get
a chance to really check in to see see
his channel I mean I've been busy today
let's just go d5 try to open it up
they'll probably take on f5 I'll take
with a Brook I'm definitely gonna be
sacking something soon oh whoa but
that's not correct at all Schuyler now I
go Bishop c3 Queen d4 and I see a
checkmate looming on the horizon oh
sorry yeah oh yeah yeah okay thank you
Joseph a thank you for letting me know
that I raided Alec earlier thank you
thank you trust fit thank you I forgot
I'm sorry I don't always remember who I
Rea
[Music]
yeah watch how they stop being so sassy
let's play Queen d4 throw out and clean
each yet I've got 96 and World Cup six I
think was just completely blacks getting
toasted here alright so now I play I
kill that torso so if you're still in
the if you're still here Ibrahim oh no
actually there's your challenge there's
I see your challenge Ibrahim up so yes I
do see your challenge
so let's play yeah I told her so also
does stream I believe so yeah Knight f3
let's play b5 something a little bit
unusual so Ibrahim off as an accident
allude iment I don't see Lou demands
challenge actually yeah I don't see a
challenge from Lou Diamond so I don't
need a challenge and I've fallen Phoenix
on cosa 8 9 7 let's play e6 wait who's
streaming whose streams are you saying
that a toll is streaming this
[Music]
Oh until its streaming this oh that's
pretty funny I played terrible opening
I'm already in a world of perfect action
lunamon I see your challenge now so
you're you're definitely on the list I'm
surprised he didn't play e5 ouch I
thought he would I'll explain try to hit
the bish up so yeah so again if you want
to play me you need to click click g5
Jericho so well I poured out on my
channel no will be port knighting on on
Alexandra's channel so I'm gonna go nie
th527 probably maybe even see 5 D 6 is
fine cheat 5 is also finite H 5 is fine
I'll play these 6 letters start still
play Knight h5 he trades a trade
[Music]
probably g3 97 something like that I
would guess is what's gonna happen here
but we'll see these chests oh goal yeah
yeah yeah no no will be a Thank You G an
accessory with a party of 33 so all of
you who are watching Ganic chasis stream
my name is Hiro Nakamura I am here on
the chest comm channel it's a sub
special sub Saturday so I am playing as
anybody who is a subscriber of the chest
channel
so I hope you guys are hope you guys are
doing well on this very fine Saturday
afternoon what kind of Sachs when we
expected fortnight well I don't know I
mean I'm not very good at four at night
but at least I understand the basics
decently thanks to thanks at chess Bay
I'll take and play like Knight b6 our
castles maybe Knight b6 next move
hey grant chess blitz how's it going
hope you're having a very nice Saturday
afternoon CTM zero-nine-five sexy car
can you do my physics homework please
chess pieces don't blame me for your
skills I thought I wasn't saying I'm not
blaming you for my skills I'm saying you
told me how to understand which guns are
good and which guns are bad how to
understand the meta part of the game so
on anyway uh before I can play c5 maybe
[Music]
I'll take with the pond I mean I'm game
I'm gambling a pawn here on a six I also
Bishop c6 maybe I can even Arthur's
there's no trick here um no there's no
trick okay let's just take I guess
so if takes like and played Bishop c6 I
don't know I don't even know what I'm
doing here I should just make a draw I'm
not exactly playing the bus game ever of
my life decline I can play e5 maybe know
if eyes no good d5 um
Thank You Jake RBA for subscribing with
a tier 2 sub I'll probably play t5 here
yeah I mean I'm not gonna lose this
games he's got no time but um but
nonetheless okay I'll take I'll take
I'll take
so if sir maybe before try to put
pressure on this pawn to e4 here JD fuss
is why such golden music because we're
on the chest comm channel and I can't
play copyrighted stuff that's why so
that's the main reason I can play Queen
d6 like it all split Queen c5 I could
play Queen d8 maybe I'll just play Queen
oh I gave him Queen 83 whoops the lips
maybe I have Queen b6 though maybe it's
still kind of okay it's not great I'm
down upon probably losing but let's see
maybe just Queen b8 maybe we can see it
to try to put pressure on this pod I
guess I could play an idea or yeah let's
see I'll just go clean f8 I guess then
a3 now do I have 94 here no I don't so
I'll play rough eh he'll trade I'll
trade oh he's got 94 whoops okay brick
e8 protect everything I'm way up on the
clock so we're t8 me oh good she's six
oh but now I'm 94 don't I I mean yes he
can take I guess and I'll go Knight of 6
again hit the pawn on d5
[Music]
d6ol just played g6 in King g7 I don't
really want to give him a draw here so
that's why I'm gonna keep playing keep
playing on maybe just g6 create a square
for my King now I can play like rookie
two or something might be 895 yeah let's
play Knight c5 let's let's go for the
victory let's go for the victory 90 oh
but DISA oh he can play DISA or oh I
forgot that Knight takes D sub was
shocked
it's check on d7 I forgot that it was
Chuck yikes
okay I mean I'll still went on time
because he's not a fast blitz player but
not not very good to say the least okay
I'll take I have five hit the rook ha ha
ha okay that was stupid I actually do
use rush room - so I'll be right back
you guys
[Music]
that's my knight c6 Bishop c4 Knight f6
alright
no no I'm not I'm not raging I actually
just ran to the brush and I need to use
the Russian for the last like three
minutes of that game okay castle fleet
e6 I guess a 6h 6 actually I put the
wrong order I might have put the wrong
water actually I'll play d6 d4 which
would be 6 @ DD 5 I just take if you
place 92 I can take on T 4 rook e1 I can
also play 94 and g5 okay we have a new
playlist apparently okay Oh see what's
on the playlist no what is this
okay need a sword play age six okay so
apparently this is the playlist Bishop
g4 thanks to I'll take on d4 take on
tape of the night oh sorry yeah I
suppose play Ibrahim oh I forgot yeah so
so I'll play ibrahim of lunamon and then
Costa 97 in that order
let me decline everybody else that I get
the right set okay they're in the next
three perfect okay let's just take it
tonight I thought a premium 94 maybe not
um take some Bishop e6 looks fine
Oh lovey is here uh lovey went one
already
lovey did you already win your game in
the South West Southwest opened that's
kind of impressive
lovey did you win let's let's look come
on lovey did you win your game or not
I'll play Quincy sucks probably take on
f3 if I can't with the rook rook e1 I
just take the knight on f3 I'm not
hearing from lovey though Oh levy drew
is game who is he playing action I'm
talking about Gotham chest he's also a
chest dreamer he was playing he's
playing the southwest open I think there
was southwest plot is southwest open I
think in Dallas Texas so just try and
see how he's doing in the tournament
guesswork a fake King update looks like
it's winning
[Music]
all right so so let's see what he's
gonna do here I place kangju toothless
is just Chuck mate let's play Ibrahim
Avila e4 um maybe uh let's I know let's
let's be the boss bot I forgot yeah yeah
see three prevent a 94 truck okay I'll
take it the pod okay I'll play a g3
Bishop g2 Knight f3 I guess I'll put the
knight on f3 probably Bishop g2 Queen C
to work d1 and the King King up one King
g1 protect the pawn first
h3 kicked the Bishop Bishop g2 worked
debunking up ones my idea
can someone explain to me why he moved
his King up a square it's cuz it's the
ball on cloud opening that's why okay he
wants a good g5 logical I'll put my tie
on g5 instead to prevent him play Queen
b3 I got the h4 is fine which page 394
Thank You Colleen for subscribing with
twitch Prime me bitched about three I
can play 93 I can also take the paw
no-go 93 tried exchanges of Queens I
should educate these fools on why is
that cryptocurrencies are flawed concept
yeah sorry twitch user three four five
to six for that specifically it's only
for today that is I'm playing subs of
this channel
um but yeah it's only for today only for
today's so I mean if you want to summon
claiming how you can you can always just
wait for the next sub Sunday on my
channel as well but this is a one-time
thing don't worry I've got work age six
or B five a for any work you want pretty
good to son of tag bond Wow
yeah you're very welcome quit cheese or
three four five just like this is just
it's just today it's just a one-time
thing so that's all it's only for today
so either way it's all good
rookies chicks did not win the Queen
seeds rook to g6 I guess I'll play
Bishop takes a seven all right let's
play a Bishop g4 try to meet him I think
I can take in queezy force checkmate
all right let's play rudiment
sorry guys I was just looking at a game
in my head
hope lately is six tonight six or C five
yeah that look was because basically
Gotham trust decided send me has he sent
me his game in a separate window so I
was just going through the game and I
was going through the game in my head
trying to understand some of his moves
which seemed kind of weird to me so yeah
basically I'm playing a game here but I
was also an I was just running through
running through like a 30 move game like
in another window as well at the same
time because that's just what I do
that's a freak queen 97 all this castle
yeah I'm just looking at Levy's game and
I saw I'm looking at in my head so I'm
playing here but I'm also thinking about
the moves in my head in his game it's
like why do you do that why do you do
that um but anyway yeah
so let's play tricky one yeah Joshua
nine six six three you have to be a some
of this channel chess bait says he card
can we be encouraging to love love I or
sorry love you looks lovely can we be
encouraging to to love you sorry I've I
just got stuck there it's like I want I
wanted to say like I want to say levy
and then I want to say Levi and I my
mind just golly my brain I said I just
have like one of those mental brain
parts they're just like sleep love a
love a love a love a love a love a love
a Kate Bush before places can be fought
on yeah we love love a
yes I'm you guys my finished running
through the subs I will actually do some
analysis of lovey's game if you want me
to
[Music]
that's a free night and I feel like
there should be a meet here somehow work
see one track and meet alright and Costa
897 now let's play d5 let's play - v e6
I do i watch black mirror yes I do I
have watched black mirror
yeah we don't have anymore sub Sun you
know what I'm gonna tell levy that he
should get on my stream and we kind of
he should get on my stream and we should
analyze the game that's what that's what
we should do or actually I can't do it
so I'm not on my channel I guess but um
but yeah we're gonna look at Lucky's
game if there are no more subs after
this sushi or wagon obviously sushi I do
like Wagyu but I do prefer Kobe beef
so wag you away I mean I guess it's all
kind of the same it's just different
quality different grade
[Music]
I'll take on a trim move up this back to
be for next move yes gf5 is fine rook
takes a seven or if d4 looks good
I think levees getting a lesson in DFO's
is happening I just take and then I take
on seats right next move he's got rook
b8 but I can play work d8 or egg name
just a
I guess Bishop d4 looks good fish eat
five or 92 is also good 92 hit the brook
hit the pawn because there's a pin on
the King as well so I'll take probably
King g3 a king h1 all / move 91 I'll see
what she would square he goes to calls
panache for I assume he slipped him at
work d7 but he's still getting made one
way or the other
cuz King is kind of boxed by the bishop
and the knight controls everything - I
think Knight f3 + rookies show is just
made next move
No
I'll play d4 on castles
[Music]
I'll play chief I've hit the pawn on
half seven twice um ah coffee man's
hoppin me indeed trying to play like me
oh that's a free rook checkmate coming
checking me so um all right you guys I
think I don't see son of tag gone online
right now
so I wait to see if he is here if he's
not here we will go to the next next
part of the stream and I will analyze I
will analyze the games or analyze the
game that levy just played in the
southwest open
[Music]
one second you guys oh no I was able to
challenge access table challenge so hmm
yeah I did challenge him
alright so there's gonna be the last sub
game and then we're gonna look at
Wingardium Leviosa and his game from
today's Southwest open to finish off the
sub Saturday stream so imma play knight
c6 i'll play Knight f6 here
so Bishop c5 Thank You LA Sox 91 for
donating $5 let's go for the kill I'm
gonna go for a sax and quick quick
attack with me so yeah so some of the
asking what time are you playing at um
I'll be playing for tonight at at 6:00
p.m. Eastern so approximately a little
under two hours I'll be playing for
tonight on Alexandra booth has the
stream Queen oh six
the elbe plank fortnight later table
will be playing squads so this is puzzle
rush night g3 I just take because
there's a pin and checkmate next move
all right um Oh Jackie the Swede sorry
Jackie the Swede where's Jackie the
sweet
all right so we'll play Jackie the Swede
no apex Legends is where it's at NACA
yeah I'll probably try apex legends at
some point but not yet that's a free
pawn
[Music]
okay I'll take what the King played out
three and came out too I guess
describe the taste hmm I don't know if I
can describe it it's got this nice like
it's not super super salty it's got like
the texture of I don't know what's it
got the texture of not sure not sure
what to say um shutter island' decent
film not my favorite though uh I do have
a puzzle right I was 37 rixy 7 Gotham
chess is in the shadows love you ready
just got like burned on the stream as I
go over a team all right guys all right
here we go
on analysis board here we go everybody
what everyone's been waiting for what
levy is probably dreading it's gonna
happen um let's see let me let me just
put in the names
okay so white is Kazarian black is
Rosman levy Rosman okay so here we go so
it should be correct this does look
correct here we go
so all right um so in this game Lobby
was black let me try to remember how to
flip the board there we go flip board no
Altaf or nonsense
um oh sorry it was a Z sorry my bad
you're right the disease maybe I can
edit that maybe I can't find I'll just
do a new analysis board sorry
i-i'll do a new analysis board it's with
a Z isn't it it's with a Z right yeah
yeah there we go
okay black Rosman okay right so okay um
alright so the game went d4 Levy played
the very questionable f5 playing the
Dutch defense not trauma the big fan of
love you playing the Dutch Levy is he is
Russian he has a Russian background so
seeing levy plays such a such a
questionable opening really makes me
think that it bought Vinick it's seen
this he would just he would just slap
levy around for playing for moving at
the half Plata move along because that
just doesn't sound right on especially
not for Russian so c4 Knight f6 Knight
c3 g6 Knight f3 g6 all pretty standard
g3 Bishop g7 Bishop g2 castles castles
and here lovie played another very
question will move he played east six um
I don't know why I love you play d6 like
96 is is one line c6 is one line I think
even Queen e8 is another line is six is
not I mean okay he's playing a lower
rated player so I understand why I love
you play d6 it would not be my personal
first choice but nonetheless it's still
a move it probably doesn't lose right
away yeah this is the line of grad
variation on the Dutch strip odds so e6
rookie one trying to play for e4 here so
now I love you play Knight e4 to prevent
that obviously if white trades the
nights after takes 92 you can maybe play
d5 even even maybe Bishop d4 94 Bishop
g7 is okay too
- so 94 is a completely logical move
white played Queen c2 here which is the
correct move Knight takes c3 B c3 Knight
to c6 and now here luvvies opponent a
the booster notes are that was the other
game bazarian did not play the move that
looks very natural here efore looks like
the very obvious move and I suspect Y
should just be much better here it would
seem like Y should be better here just
optically speaking so if you take white
takes this diagonal is open also there's
pressure on the e6 pawn there's maybe
Knight g5 Bishop g5 even rook e1 to put
more pressure down this diagonal as well
so I don't know it seems like it seems
like why should just be better here
clearly better I would say um but okay
white didn't do that white played Bishop
to e3 now keep in mind White was not
2700 she I'm White was in 20 to 20 so
it's understandable sufficient III was
played I love you played e5 here which
again like I mean this is why I like
white why do you play six and then e5
losing a tempo this kind of reeks of a
open like low quality open open
tournament shots in the US which is kind
of everyone just does what they have to
do to try and try and just get the get
the B with white or black as opposed to
trying to play high-quality cha so very
questionable choice to play D 6 + e5 but
I mean ok it's a move so de 5 D takes e5
I mean but see like this I don't
understand you like why should white
take on c5 why should not take on e5
like I mean why should just play like c5
probably or even maybe just rook b1 and
I don't know I feel like Y should be
better here
maybe but again it's all very I'm very
skeptical of both players play because
if you think about the opening logically
in this position white white put the
rook on e 1 so if you put the rook on
one the whole point is to play for e4 so
to like play knight c6 and then go
Bishop e3 and prevent yourself from
playing or just makes no sense at all
like what is this guy doing um
I of course I'm being fairly humorous
about joking with levy but like his
opponents Armenian like Armenians
generally are very good a positional
understanding so it's a way that they're
both playing is very very peculiar and
just flat-out just strange to me I don't
I don't really understand it like you
don't put the bishop on e3 you play for
afor that's the whole point of going
rook e1 that's the whole point you want
to go eat for uh-uh-uh
yeah I'm gonna lose my mind pretty soon
at these moves because they just it's
not good chess but anyway yeah like but
point it out it's like when you put the
bishop on III now after E 5 de de also
black and go E for it open the long
diagonal and again you don't have a four
so on yeah Bishop III is yeah smells
like a bad move Bishop III does not seem
like a good move very very disappointing
move to play so yeah I don't know what Y
was thinking putting the fish money III
makes no sense at all
so he gets Bishop c5 rook e8 e gets his
he for now but he's gotten a four but at
the quality of having these double
isolated C pawns and also why it's not
really threatening to ever take so you
can just take and go e4 anyway or even
Bishop e6 and hit the pawn on c4 so it's
I don't know I don't really like the way
that why just play this I feel like
blacks should already be better at this
point like maybe not much better but I
feel like blacks would be better the
Bishop on c5 is questionable there's
these double C pawns that don't really
do much
you also don't really have threats on
the diagonal anymore
a black center is pretty solid here just
not a fan of what white he's done here
so alright so clean up this is played he
takes out five logical of course if you
play d1 the black goes up for now
there's g5g for the diagonal is
permanently closed you can't open it
anymore
so so here at EF v is plead or not v
sorry GF v work ad one can promote moose
over KT one and now he for probably
correct yeah II four should be correct
because you need to close diagonal maybe
Bishop e6 is possible first to hit the
pawn on c4 but it's probably not great
so there's maybe Queen b3 actually I
wonder is fishing east looks better than
eat for ride weeks maybe you delay it
and you just try to win this pawn first
fish should be six 95 95 Bishop d4 and
yeah Bishop c4 f4 and clean up seven
yeah but this is probably fine for white
so I understand it okay so II forest
fine yeah I understand before it makes
sense to e4 94 b6 logical Bishop eight
three of course if white takes on c6
then you would take on c5 and these this
pawn kind of controls some nice squares
from the knight c3 is loose
I just Bishop e6 and you're gonna clean
up all the pawns on c3 and c4 so so fish
a3 played fish a3 and now let me plate
95 I guess he's saying 95 was bad 95 he
thought he's making progress and after
f3 levies like like Olivia's like at me
I've just messed up everything it's
gonna be a draw um okay so let's let's
let's take a look at this okay so
so Bishop a3 let's see so how can black
play for the win here is a big question
here on let's see so if you play 95 f3 I
guess it's hard to play all the c4 c4 Fe
4 maybe not so good so let's see what
are the candidate moves this is the
first question um 95 is obvious 95 is
obvious those are two very obvious
candidate moves are there any other
moves as the other questions 95 I mean
maybe f3 anyway is a problem because
it's the same thing as playing 95 98 see
for the I don't like 95 so let's see
94 would be utterly insane because then
you just undal the pawns so are there
any other moves to play here is black
[Music]
hmm okay 95 you can't play Bishop e6 is
Bishop e6 with hang the knight on c6 so
you can't coefficient East 6 on hmm
maybe there just is nothing special here
for uh Oh [__] up a 6 ya bish B is 6
but Bishop a 6 I think runs into there
are a few things first I think white can
again play off 3 and now if you push III
you hang the pawn on out 5 FY can take
then this whole diagonal is gonna open
and blocks got a bunch of problems so
Bishop e6 doesn't look look right um no
okay so 95 I think is the correctness 95
f3 let's see now if you take I guess
this white would take here cuz on night
a3 there's Queen b3 check and then Queen
83 like Queen f7 Queen 83 and white is
probably a touch better not much better
I don't think what White's probably a
little bit better here yeah there should
be some then white plays Knight takes
off 5 and you lose a pawn
hmm so let's see okay I have after Fe
for now F before it's already gone so
you can't take on c4 okay let's see so
here what what else can we do
what about c5 obviously five is gonna
take on e4 I guess because if you take
on cd4 and E 5 is coming so okay let's
see hmm what else is there here yeah I
don't really see anything great what
line let me tell me aligned OC 5 fe 4 F
4 ah okay actually oh yeah yeah this
makes a lot of sense actually cuz now
you can play off three of tonight moves
but I mean it's hard to play this I mean
because are you really threatening to
take d4 or not that's another question
cuz if white takes and gets to eat five
it's the same same thing like I don't
rook f1 maybe I mean I don't know I
don't know what's going on here although
maybe now you can no you can't really
take after makes no sense night c4
there's always gonna be a Queen b3 rook
up for
[Music]
English on glass s'il vous parlez
Anglais parlez-vous anglais Matt know
maybe 94 maybe after three then later
after work takes up 400 you're saying
you're supposed to take we hope our
angle a CD for like what Queen g6 or
what I know this is too weird though
this is too weird
I mean Rick up one is I mean maybe it's
flying for the computer but this seems
very very hard to play as a human very
very hard to play this as a human so I
don't blame lovey for this um I mean I
guess the question is was there anything
better maybe if I go back so I didn't
like I don't like this Bishop III move
like is white playing for d5 or not I I
don't think white is playing for d5
really here so is there a need to play
e5 or can you maybe just put like a six
g5 or are there other ideas too like 95
maybe only 95 I guess 92 92 I don't see
anything here so let's see yeah I don't
I don't know I don't like a 5v5 just
it's got that feel like something's
wrong to it so I don't know I don't know
about e5 um let's see so but it's a hard
position to play because again you
played this you voices tempo on e6 on a1
d5 what D 5 might be an improvement I
don't know I don't know something seems
wrong about this position it just it
doesn't seem right to me for either side
really but I mean I guess the problem is
this is black or just you're cramped
you're not really fighting for the
center um okay h6 okay let's see so if
you play h6 because there's no e for
idea Bishop is going nowhere I mean is
white really playing d5 here or not as a
question
like d5 Knight a5 Queen a4 yeah this is
bad for blah okay so I guess d5 is is
legit legitimates right here for white
[Music]
so let's it's the game eath 'if I've
does seem right the more I think about
the more I like 'if I've I don't see
anything else that really makes sense
unless you're gonna play like nice he's
not ninety something it's terrible it
makes no sense okay so II five takes
take Bishop c5 rook e8 e for now maybe
there's something better instead of
Queen f6 like here maybe you should play
out before yeah actually why not have
four here lucky why not have four yeah
maybe up or here makes more sense act
now I think about it yeah at for I think
is a good move here I don't know if
point can take maybe and play e5 maybe
um maybe that's the idea it takes takes
e5 um I mean there's the other question
here you can black play Bishop c4 maybe
as well but still probably work t1 I
don't know maybe not
if takes this must be good for black you
control f4 should be should be good for
black um let's see so Bishop chief for
no f5 between f6 h 3 v h5 4 KD 1 messy
hard to play so let's see so jeah okay
so GF t f4 KD 1 clean off 65 notice this
probably is this bad probably it's
probably ok for block that after takes
94 White's okay - um so if we don't play
efore do we have any other moves do we
have a thief or maybe very unusual move
arcade d1 but then rookie do you want
coin op 690 yeah no this is bad ok so
clean up sexy f5
what about Bishop f5 maybe clean us to
move somewhere if Queen b3 then Knight
a5 and d6 looks pretty good for black so
I don't like Queen b3
it's like Queen B - maybe just b6 Bishop
e3
[Music]
maybe 1985 here as it's possible to play
Gotham chess says computer slowly liking
out for G up for Bishop g4 that's why
you're super GM and I'm almost yeah yeah
but I mean again this is very hard to
play like I mean okay like like f/4g up
for Bishop g4 I mean this does not seem
clear to me at all as a humans to why
this should be why this should be great
for white or for black I mean f5 I mean
like cleanup 6 h3 for speech 551 like I
mean okay black is probably fine but
this is just this just ass hard to play
as a human but yeah I mean maybe that's
that maybe that's the one chance that or
this Bishop about 5 is what I'm
wondering but maybe white can just be
solved with Queen e2 and b6 Bishop e3 in
the 92 is coming although there are CC
pawn so it's nothing special for white
but I suspect this should be fine so
yeah I don't know I'm no I'm not sure
what you mean to this but oh well anyway
I would say yeah a for Bishop g4 is
probably the best try or this [__]
about five one of the two that's what I
would say one of the two makes sense so
yeah I don't know strange very strange
very strange but interesting game
nonetheless played by levy today he drew
of his first game today so hopefully he
will come back strong and win the game
tonight that he's playing shortly so to
be shelled with wish levy good luck in
the in the next round
I assume he's gonna head off and start
prepping eat lunch prepare play sleep
play more chess because that's what you
do when you play open tournaments on so
decent game decent game no big mistakes
at least so that's a big plus that's a
very big plus for a lobby so yeah we
should always love you good luck and
then
and and I guess you know I'm gonna head
over since we played all the subs
already then gonna head over and finish
this stream with some puzzle rush so
just give me one second
and unless let's uh let's head over and
do some puzzle rush let's do some puzzle
rush ok so that's a free queen
that's a checkmate that's a chat take
Queen
that's a checkmate this is a free night
shotgun Queenie such as meat steaks just
chuck me checking cakes
check and check into twelve three just
check and take the bishop just check and
mate I guess Bishop d3 and rook e1 is me
check and take the Queen
I guess just Ricky one and take the
Queen just check and take the Queen oh I
met work t500 I met Ricky five oh so sad
so sad I'm at work t5 but maybe it's a
new pieces too because like with the new
pieces and sometimes you slip so let's
take the knight
what is 95 free Brooke you say 3e - I
just - Bishop c3 just take stock and
meat just check and pick up the night
just Chuck just King takes age to take
the Queen
oh that's Chuck chucking meat night a
poor trade the Queen's take the bishop
95 take the Queen probably Thank You
hybrid mutant for donating five hundred
bits think thanks for that thanks for
the outer hours content you're very
welcome
um play night before girls play 96
I can't split queen III let's think
about this front side so what is quite
threatening anything no so I can just
play Rakesh a rookie 194 is just a free
piece looks good just queen seasick can
take the night take the bishop let's
check and make a queen just shocking
shocking meet Queen before track and
take cake no P 293 make a queen probably
look at five and just clean out three
and takes five maybe this takes okay
this Queen d7 93 is the foreign King g1y
is trying to make a queen so you go king
b5
I guess you take you play 54 you take
lady should be four make a queen make a
check Queen rook d4 is move chief 554
looks good okay so you're trying to push
this pawn up the board so must be Chuck
and g7 Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck
very good King g5h or wait blacks
turning me here so you've got to be
careful now it's Rick h5 Chuck edge
foreign mate just takes it takes that's
good
Queen g5 to move Bishop e5 is a move for
keep five also a move way too many moves
wide so many moves Queen f5 also looks
completely fine
[Music]
garbage Chuck right Chuck this is just
oh it's Chuck Chuck Chuck and me okay
good it's gotta be shocked oh wait
it's a d6 or not it's not these six I
don't think
oh no it is it's Chuck Chuck and me wow
what a crazy one um this probably takes
is it rookie aid yes it is okay it's
gotta be takes it's got me Chuck
[Music]
you take there's always King e7 so it's
not take something like rook b7
oh no it's Rick h7 Chuck and me okay
very good
okay now 92 and 95 both work so I mean
okay yeah hey it's me
oh come on come on
so bad dad alright let's go again
it's a free Brooke Chuck me Chuck me
Chuck Nate it's Chuck Nate just Chuck
Nate Chuck Nate just Chuck Nate
this takes take this show oh and imagine
you know I should have had 51 because I
slept that previous when I slipped I met
Rick D 5 and I slipped so I actually
should have had 51 not not 50 because
the first one I got wrong with just
complete mouseland which i forgot about
completely I just make a queen and take
the Queen so just takes and rook d7
looks good just checking I too for a
community one looks good just takes
Anarchy one looks good just
takes and repeat one checkmate
must be shocking take it should be
before okay very weird chok chok and
tape so [__] page seven shock shock and
mate it's just Chuck in Queens v1 it's
mate 95 and queen g4 is made 47 and rook
t1 and just from before Bishop C 394 is
winning g3 and take the bishop just
three obviously just takes takes takes
show this takes shotgun take to make a
queen and make a night and take the
queen make it Chuck make a Chuck make a
Chuck make a check put the rook make a
rookie for maybe yeah so take the rope
and take the rook check and make a mate
make a Chuck make a Chuck make a snack
[Music]
just Bishop e3 and take the Night Man
a 94 no that's way tonight I find I see
five and there's about five is good
95 take the road can take the Queen see
it's no good for be eight and double the
rooks maybe yep very good there's a g3
okay what's maybe this 90 453 yeah and
just takes it takes it's very good she
won and I just take and just take and
make me must be Chuck must be okay well
you got a check there's some way to make
a stalemate here there's got to be a
stalemate
it's got to be like how does he make
this tell me chief or takes takes
yeah yeah work d5 and queen sita's good
[Music]
94 Bishop f2 or Bishop actually what
about Bishop up - and shocking we ate
meat we can plate take on d3 and play
Knight of five very good or catch a
torque or g8 or Bishop f8y a bishop a
feint takes very good I mean obviously
the wait no it's not takes the knight p7
ours at 96
I'm guessing it's night b7 and cheery
that's very good
rook h5 maybe takes shock Bishop b4 and
just take the rook
Queenie wants to move rook F - looks
strong also and just takes and just take
them which Bishop do you take again oh
you take this one okay good
must be well it's got to be a check it
could be rook a 4 or b4 b4 okay one I
don't think it's be for my gut tells me
it's not before here so my instinct is
that it should be rook a 4 but no Burke
a 4 is no it's just got to be before it
just takes what what on earth Wow okay
um okay I've still got plenty of time
though I've only got one wrong okay
cheese seven root G - let me check
shocking okay spot even McQueen
oh man just queer cage oh my gosh
oh no it's putting up 70 X okay good
Queen B to us um oh my gosh
shocking work f2 okay you cheat or is a
cheat
oh no that's not good not good not good
we go again go again now it's just not
gonna get it done that's just not gonna
get it done it's me Chuck and meet Chuck
meet Chuck pick up the brook just takes
and rugby to chuck me shocking me just
take the Queen and make a mate just
Chuck take Sandra get you one
chuck it mate just take it takes just
trade everything take the [__] Monty
for worksheet 1 and take the rough night
take the night make it rock mate let's
go let's go 94 let's make a mate let's
take let's pick the Queen let's took a
bishop make a check the brook
just checking Queen Easter is made
Queenie for looks like me just fish 46
and take them take that
96 in mistakes ok very good 5 4 speech
to pick up Queen just chuck it just
Chaka Chaka take Brooke age 3 Chuck and
Chuck and me just rocky 6 it's good just
to 7 and it's take is good just for cage
sex takes made us good what are you
doing what are you doing
96 44 is me Chuck and fish bait three
his mate
[Music]
why me just check and take and just take
the rook we know it's Chuck and Chuck
it's take some ticks Chuck and cheese
six and just take the Queen just takes
me the Queen t37 the Chuck Chuck neither
for a mate should be wait no wait no
it's better to see one trap the Queen
[Music]
takes and just take the Queen very good
43 Chuck Chuck and mate
dc2 is no good 94 is a move 98 for and I
don't know mate c3 yeah okay good just
okay you want to take the Queen Chuck
Chuck um let's see Queen III is a move
I've got 44 I'm really doing well Queen
e1 Kings II duties I can't be Queen e1
King D - so is it may be Queen III night
h5 yeah okay good very good
may just be shocked I'm shocked very
good hey 6a v g3 a6 g2 or Ricky sub no
it's not working so just takes a 5 good
or Bishop f3 bishop um let's see um cuz
it may be just take some Bishop c5 I'm
just shocked and me get very good I've
got so much time here like I've got so
much time let's go let's go
must be jacked in 94 93 good
eggs Chuck takes good oh shoot
oh wait wait goes on oh shoot uh I was
not expecting that
Bishop c1 Wow so hard why is it giving
me the hard problems I didn't ask for
hard problems I guess let's work these
seven or if d1 and takes Queen h7 King
up eight-track and rookie five you have
six this is it boys this is it we're
getting fifty five this is it boys let's
go
Rick h7 King g6 f5 rookie 7 yes come on
come on oh man 53 53 let's go let's go
ok King e1 push page 5 oh shoot rookie
for rookie for Bishop g5 working for
Bishop g5 on King e1 push page 5 oh
shoot I should probably just guess I
know I should just guess there okay
that's fine that's fine I need to guess
though um h6 good be nice okay
oh no no no no no oh no oh oh okay one
more one more let's let's get the record
enough nonsense let's just get the
frickin record takes 16h - shocking meet
Chuck takes a pinch of seven just Chuck
Chuck and mate c3 and chucking meet now
you foreign kick rook takes takes takes
mix corn me up for the night [__]
mate
Chuck cake it's not one is it no you've
got to Brooks get real comfy one I'd be
Chuck Chuck Chuck me eh - how did I miss
that
[Music]
Chuck and takes okay I guess we need
five and make a queen
let's put you chief for pickup Queen
just D 5 C 6 and cakes oh sorry there's
something writing for the camera
okay sorry you guys let me pull us a
little bit better
okay that's probably better that's gonna
cost me a shot at 55 but whatever so be
it Chuck Chuck and Chuck and me how did
I miss that
I'll get shotgun just take the Queen and
one just Chuck pick the rook just Chuck
takes Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck and
d3 his mate goes for three and Chuck
mate just takes Chuck cakes 92 or
Kingdom I guess night okay whatever
takes takes shot pigs Chuck and there's
got to be a force major it's a night of
5 H 5 it is indeed but retains and it's
gotta be takes it's got to be just I
mean takes okay shock should be shocked
should be what's me we know it's just
Chuck chucking me okay
just takes and just takes reps c6 and c5
and takes just takes on 85 candy five I
guess that's three cause wrong
okay what's my move white pawns are what
going up the board cookie king cheese
six it could also be a bishop age
oh it's fish pH for fish b1 bishops III
I'm king g6 is winning Queen c2 no
threat just takes and just takes b4
Bishop e5 and just Chuck takes takes
oh no not one of these ones shoot 96
Knight a5 good Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck
Chuck and Nate okay good
rookie for or Bishop before what is this
right here I don't know
ridiculous
oh my gosh and it goes on
I don't believe too much too much
okay one more you guys one last one one
last one one last I lost all my time
side to just a webcam in the middle
there so that's why I wasn't gonna get
fifty that time I'll go checkmate takes
90 98 96 I'm just shocked mate if I take
the Queen just shocked okay
and it goes on early this is insanely
hard problem for like the what am I
missing here
like what on earth is this
or that wasn't that was ridiculous I was
like the eats problem I must have been
missing something really obvious there
we need five and just takes Ching f2
tracking takes takes and take the Queen
I just take the bishop
a foreign takes c1 it takes just takes
and mate takes checkmate
d4 takes and takes we do six just wait
no no it's fish before right thank you
trade okay for and take the bishop check
and mate okay just take take okay so it
should be a way to win here for black
apparently is it just no it's not
Queenie 6 q g5 we have four how do you
win here oh wait no sorry black pawns
are what going they're going they're
going the right way okay good he's
framing
good enough night before obviously so
bad all right you guys one more one last
one yeah that was just that that that
was like the eighth problem I'm wonder
if I missed something really obvious so
all right one more you guys let's make a
mate let's go Chuck mate
let's take the piece take the pawn Chuck
and take the knight but should be five
and take the Queen just take the knight
make mate just go check in and mate just
be five between just take and take the
knight just go 44 pick up the rook 7m8
there's three and take between just
check and take the knight on a sudden
take the rook checkmate there should be
a major point you to make you one no
it's just Chuck Chuck and yeah it just
takes good Queen c4 is a move Bishop g5
I guess okay that looks good let's just
a check and between 26 and Chuck and me
B to a7 make a queen take rook takes 90
3 d 3 C 3 C 2 just takes and Queen h5
and take the bishop mr. Jack and go six
seven we not threes a move
Catherine must be right in rock h2
other order other order apparently takes
28 take cakes looks good
how do you create a passed pawn this way
yeah Queen wait yeah this before of a
few seven of her kitchen three is me it
sucks in meat it's got to be 95 right
it's gotta be nitrogen bottom link Queen
g6 it is okay d3 is wrong d7 95 looks
good Queen she 898 or no Queen G it is
me because you've got the rook on f1
okay let's see 97 oh no it's Bishop c6
first and the night g7 chuckling me no
it's not Queen III Queen Chi - no it's
not cleaning through Queen G - just
let's try and show that alright so this
one it should be Chuck first wait wait a
second okay there's 52 King do you want
yeah yeah it's a Chuck and then Chuck
and that's good we take 94 that's good
oh wait bad yeah yeah just too much too
much that 54 just killed me not getting
it not getting not getting the ax 54 not
getting that 55th just killed me because
like when you got such a big row and
then you just like it's such a letdown
when you can't get that 55 that's such a
huge letdown
man such a huge letdown but uh I should
have gotten that one too I had 15
seconds that's gonna kill me for like it
and that's like 30 minutes but yeah
anyway you guys hope you enjoyed the sub
salary that 54 I think really spiced it
up at the end so I will be back in an
hour on Alexandra stream for fortnight
but I'm gonna head on out now and so
I'll catch up with everybody in an hour
and and I'll be back on Monday so you
guys very well for the stream and I'll
see you on Alexandra stream in an hour
so until then good bye